Devès devrait signer le décret.
- La con est palpable
à La Baie, où un autre
glissement de terrain
menace de se produire.
Par mesure préventive,
53 familles on dû quitter
leur demeure dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche.
L'ordre d'évacuation pourrait
durer plusieurs mois.
- Honnêtement, je te dirais que,
écoute, c'est un csue
un peu, là. T'sais, moi,
j'ai su ça aux environs de 10 h.
- Bien, nous, on n'a pas
de famille ici. Mais,
en tout cas, on va voir, là,
qu'est-ce qu'il vae qu'il va se.
- C'est quand même
un investissement.
Mon fils est né là-dedans,
dans cette maison-là, puis tout.
Hier, j'ai pris un bon
deux, trois heures; je me suis
promené, je me suis assis
dans chaque pièce,
chaque chambre, tout.
- Le moral... On n'est pas
dans la rue. Je suis chez
ma soeur. Il y en a qui sont
pires que moi, là, j'imagine.
Il y a un monsieur qui disait
qu'il n'avait même pas
de place où aller coucher
ce soir.
- Tout est mis en branle,
à Saguenay, afin de reloger
plus de 180 sinistrés.
Plusieurs solutions sont
envisagées et la déclaration
de l'état d'urgence facilitera
le travail.
ANDRÉE LAFOREST, ministre resp.,
région du Saguenay-Lac-St-Jean
- Alors ça, ça va donner
la possibilité à Ville Saguenay
et ici, à M. Girard,
le directeur, de prendre
des décisions cons
que oui, c'est un état
d'urgence, malheureusement,
mais heureusement, tout le monde
est en vie. On parle avec
l'Office de l'habitation
depuis le début, alors il y a
des logements qui sont
maintenant disponibles.
Ça, ça a rassuré beaucoup
les citoyens.
JULIE DUFOUR,
mairesse de Saguenay
- Une multitude de solutions,
mais avant, un, il faut
connaître le besoin.
On a-tu des familles?
On a-tu des personnes âgées
à mobilité réduite? Donc,
c'est vraiment les besoins,
mais tout est ouvert, du terrain
de camping en passant par
la résidence de personnes âgées,
par la résidence éésidence éési,
par la famille ou des bons
samaritains.
- D'autres expertises
seront faites prochainement
pour analyser le sol.
Les experts estiment
que sa composition ressemble
à celle de Saint-Jean-Vianney,
où un glissement de terrain
avait coûté la vie
à 31 pe mai 1971.
Les autorités sont
sur le qui-vive.
CAROL GIRARD, dir., Serv. de
sécurité incendie,
- À l'heure actuelle, écoute,
c'est un risque de mouvement
de sol imminent. Donc,
c'est sûr et certain quetout po.
Mais notre priorité, c'était
d'évacuer le plus rapidement
possible.
le continue son travail
pour tenter de limiter
les dégâts. Des digues
sont installées pour retenir
un éventuel glissement.
rielle Morissette,
Radio-Canada, Sag